we have to end the sanctuary cities crap
fast fast
there are more than 200 cities and
counties across the US with policies
instructing local law enforcement not to
investigate the immigration status of
suspects or prisoners in their custody
these sanctuary cities are a target of
the GOP this primary season with
candidates jumping to characterize them
as lawless city states whose leaders
have blood on their hands as these
mayors these city officials they are
partners in crime they should be held
criminally liable as accomplices I don't
think you can have whole cities or whole
states just not obeying the law San
Francisco has been a sanctuary city
since 1989 there are 300 of them and
meanwhile what has happened nothing on
July 1st Kate Steinle was walking with
her father along pier 14 in San
Francisco when a bullet ricocheted off
the ground struck her in the back and
killed her the gunman was an illegal
immigrant from Mexico and Juan Francisco
Lopez Sanchez Kate Steinle was hardly
the first case but because she was young
she was attractive the guy who killed
her was about as disgusting as you could
come up with it caught along with the
press and it was a story that you know
had to be covered
Don Rosenberg is an activist affiliated
with Californians for population
stabilization an anti-immigration group
and he writes about the danger of
unlicensed drivers of his website
unlicensed to kill he experienced a
personal tragedy when an illegal
immigrant lacking a driver's license hit
his son with his car and then ran over
him several times trying to escape by
that time a man in the in a car in the
intersection had gotten out and stood in
front of his car and he stopped and his
rear tire was on my son's abdomen took
five people to lift the car off of him
but he was already dead at that point
Rosenberg believes that the common
thread connecting the death of Steinle
and that of his own son is the city of
San Francisco itself a sanctuary city
sanctuary city policies are clearly
illegal obstruction of justice if you or
I tried to
protect somebody in the country
illegally particularly somebody who
would you know committed a crime we
would go to jail that doesn't give the
city the right to do it san Francisco's
sheriff Rossmore karim is at the center
of the media storm that followed the
murder of Kate Steinle after all it was
one of his jails that released Lopez
Sanchez
despite transfer requests from
Immigration and Customs Enforcement
but Mirkarimi says he was following the
law through the last 25 years the City
and County of San Francisco has been
very sensitive to the question of
immigration and to the plight of
undocumented people's about a quarter
century ago a number of laws of just
sanctuary city laws have been passed by
our Board of Supervisors in 2013 a
different kind of law was passed by our
Board of Supervisors and signed into
effect by the current mayor called due
process for all that helps stipulate a
limited interface between law
enforcement and immigration customs and
enforcement so do you believe that
sanctuary city policies make law
enforcement job easier and make the
community safer I do and I think in a
state like California in a city like San
Francisco being on the Pacific Rim and
being such a hub for diverse non-english
speaking immigrant and undocumented
populations you could see the contrast
in years before where there had been no
sanctuary city laws or due process for
all laws where it was actually
undermining and subverting Public Safety
because of the lack of collaboration and
cooperation between government law
enforcement and and those communities
mercury mieze argument that sanctuary
city policies increased cooperation with
law enforcement is difficult to measure
but a survey out of the University of
Illinois found that 45% of Latinos
stated that they are less likely to
voluntarily offer information about
crimes and 45% are less likely to report
a crime because they are afraid the
police will ask them or people they know
about their immigration status and in
general first-generation immigrants a
quarter of whom are undocumented are far
less likely to commit violent or
property
than native-born Americans even if it
was true that illegal aliens committed
less crime than citizens every crime
they commit is an additional crime that
shouldn't have happened it might be true
that if you let fewer people in the
country and reduce the population there
would be fewer crimes overall but this
scenario would likely involve some
combination of mass deportations an
invasive employer verification system
the ability of police to ask for your
citizenship papers at every traffic stop
and billions of dollars more spent on
border control and the bottom line is
that San Francisco is not significantly
more dangerous than non sanctuary cities
of a similar size and in fact
experienced far fewer murders than many
of them it's hard to stop lone wolves
like Lopez Sanchez who didn't have a
violent record his felony record was a
litany of drug charges and illegal
border crossings why he fired a gun on
pier 14 that fateful evening remains a
mystery Kate Steinle death is a terrible
perhaps inexplicable tragedy to just
point finger at sanctuary city or to
vilify because of this tragedy may feel
good and venting about their
frustrations and anger but it's only
going to unravel
I think the good work over all that is
being done to build the kind of trust
that needs to be built with these
communities in the first place
politicians and pundits are always
talking about importance of high-tech
foreigners for the US economy but the
fact of the matter is that low-skilled
immigrants make equally vital
contributions and here are five reasons
why